[Music]  don't start to worry what happened when  I went to Vietnam  you came home okay and what happened  when it went out fur  you came home I always come home dozen  high-ranking terrorist for planning war  hell of a party  exactly when and where we do not know  but what we do know is that there is  information out there and I'm gonna  saying you go get it yes sir this is a  one-way ticket these are my orders Peter  this is a suicide mission  [Music]  Kelly is it a coma is the intelligence  fully retrievable we would destroy our  agent in the process that was too risky  with my pants tonight  when he upset the business final they're  gonna have to kill me if they want to  kill him what was his mission it's  classified contestants looking for  answers  the wife has attempted to get  intelligence  [Music]  don't get in our way you have  intelligence that'll save millions alive  [Music]  you have to accept the reality of the  situation here  welcome to nah no terror  you